it says other than honorable maybe it's
like a barely right below skirting right
like a misdemeanor instead of a felony
or something like that
I knew them with this many I always
thought there's two honorable
dishonorable yeah
[Music]
so I have a list here and I thought you
would be a great help clarifying A lot
of these things because I've always been
curious about it uh there's a list of
all the different ways you can be
discharged from the military oh [__] oh
really I would like to understand these
better yeah because I've always wondered
what happened no idea and I know there
were so many either
so the first one is too
I seriously
good they were going what is the third
one like disability right yeah
disability that's technically honorable
yeah there's like eight on this list
I know someone who got discharged this
dishonorably oh I think I know who that
is
good to know
injured really bad
boot camp uh-huh and he like told them
like yo his leg's all [__] up and then
they didn't really take care of him so
he called his buddy to meet him and he
escaped the that one by San Diego to go
to the hospital oh wow oh really yeah oh
so he basically fleed yeah to go to the
hospital yeah treated
that's a good that's an example of a
dishonorable yeah so
um number one honorable discharge that's
what you guys like a plus yeah yeah
good job but why do they call it
discharge though because it's sexy yeah
they should call it like honorable
graduation oh that's nice
and then and then dishonorable discharge
sounds good it's like you got [__]
out of the system
pop the pimple yeah yeah so there's
another one one called General discharge
oh General discharge it says here that
it means most of your service was okay
but some problems occurred you ever
heard of that no why does it sound like
it's issued when a person shows a
pattern of minor misconduct or fails to
complete the original service contract
wow so what would that be CD student and
just like okay I have never met anyone
get BuzzFeed right this [__]
military.com do you still get a a
certificate I oh it says you you get it
if the service member leaves the
military for things such as physical
Readiness failure or Parenthood
Parenthood usually you're still entitled
to many veteran benefits but some
employers May question you why you've
got fired like so you're just like like
a pregnant lady in boot camp I'm not
sure what that means but or Parenthood I
don't know that sounds like someone got
pregnant while in dude like could you be
a piece of [__] parent you could also be
a dad maybe and then uh your wife passed
away and you're in charge of taking care
of it to like go back it can't be
deployed or something I don't know do
you know what an oth is
this is called other than honorable
discharge whoa
they look great and it's also known as a
bad paper discharge you didn't file your
papers properly what military is this
that's interesting yeah it says um it
means you got fired from the military
for doing something very bad and we're
probably lucky to escape a court martial
that's not dishonorable yeah that would
be this average it says other than
honorable maybe it's like a barely right
below skirting right like a misdemeanor
instead of a felony or something like
this
this many I always thought there's two
honorable dishonorable yeah
there's sections within the sections it
says that um it could include such
things as drug use fighting abusive
position or disobeying an order veteran
benefits are usually not authorized but
you can find it hard to get a good job
this is probably just like the the head
honchos in the military like they just
would hear people do crazy [__] and
they'd be like well what do we
categorize this we have to come up with
other things other than honorable sounds
so good this needs another category you
know no how about a BCD you need the
Tofu House I love that place it's a bad
conduct discharge you hear that bat boy
what's an example about bad conduct like
fighting off a base or something well
this one says it's a punitive discharge
that can be imposed as punishment by the
court-martial for serious offenses
um following a finding of a guilty for a
military offense it almost just sounds
like a dishonorable but uh it says it
can be given if someone exhibits a
pattern of convictions for Miss conduct
that indicates they are unfit to serve
so maybe it's like if you keep repeating
the same mistake but that mistake wasn't
necessarily massive but you just did it
a lot yeah I like that I'm just getting
looks results
I wish they would put like the dates
when they made these yeah they must be
old yeah oh yeah because this is from
actual military.com wow
interesting okay now we're on
dishonorable it'll be interesting to see
the stats too of which branches give
some of those out yeah maybe it's like
National Guard only because like maybe
some of them are more paperwork heavy
because then also I know like some units
if you're like not squared away they'll
just make your life a living [__]
hell until you get square so you never
even reaches paperwork because they know
they don't want to they're trying not to
screw your life over either like once
you have something to hit your like
service record book they don't want to
like something continuously affect you
so they almost much rather like I'm just
gonna make your life a living hell until
you get your [__] together all right
cool like take that as a favor you know
versus me writing you up and then now
it's permanently under [__] I see but
then in like more baby paperwork heavy
unit they might just like I don't mind a
deal with him you know
that have is a lot those admin units
would probably be yeah I bet you in
infantry for sure it's just like they'll
smoke your ass until you get your shifts
away and that then yeah you're carrying
four machine guns yeah and like you want
to get your [__] together yeah and then
you're like okay I will do that again
fire watch like more ties that you
should do and make you wax the floor
more times than everybody else yeah wow
those are actually like a favor to you
because you're not it's not on your
permanent like record you know is
firewatch like when you're on guard all
night yeah you're on guard all night
cheese so the dishonorable it says here
it's usually when someone commits a
felony level offense
either in the military or as a civilian
like those marines that are fighting
those kids the reason San Clemente yeah
yeah see that no these uh Marines uh
said they were on San Clemente Beach uh
just like enjoying a day off and that
these teenagers were off to the side
having a party shooting fireworks and
then they said one of the fireworks hit
one of the Marines so they went over
there to ask the kids hey stop shooting
fires but they had to take his shirt off
first yeah yeah and then they end up
getting in a kind of like a scuffle with
these teens and then basically it was
nine teens or actually 40 teams against
three servicemen and then uh later on of
them parting together footage came out
of them actually partying together and
the dudes actually with their shirts off
like play fighting with each other and
then I guess it it extended from that
situation
now as as both a police officer and
prior military if you arrived on that
scene like how would you process it I've
been like uh 19 Paul turn around
no I'd be like what the [__]
you like is that's the one thing being
the cats like you thought you saw it all
but there's some calls are just like wow
this is [__] my that's like a
mind-blowing call I I would I don't know
what a story huh yeah when cops go back
to their patrol car
give me a minute is that them like going
back to like what the [__]
yeah
we talked to my partner for a second
yeah there's also officer discharge
and uh it says a commissioned officer
cannot receive a bad conduct discharge
or a dishonorable discharge for them the
equivalent of a dishonorable discharge
is an officer's discharge oh I didn't
know that what are these for I guess
it's just a file how different people
get kicked out so then like you can't
come back or something because when
you're done you're done right so like is
the employer gonna look at and be like I
don't know about this I mean I can't
even imagine most employers would even
know the difference if it's not that
common anyway most of them you can write
I went to Harvard and they don't even
ask you for your diploma I mean most
employers yeah
then there's medical discharge which is
uh it's not considered punitive and in
terms of veteran benefits it's typically
seen in the same category as honorable
veteran discharge medical discharge oh
medical and then there's entry level
separation heard of that oh yeah that
one is I think if you don't finish boot
camp like something happened right like
you [__] yeah crazy shin splint or
something if you leave within the first
180 days yeah yeah that's usually for
medical yeah that's what our buddy could
have had yeah but he but he's down
[__] escape to go to the hospital was
his leg really that bad I don't know
he's a problem boy so you know who does
whatever the [__] he wants my brother
broke his leg in the Army yeah and they
said just kept him to the hill yeah yeah
you can do that you can do that cool
he's an army right now
good he did a Korean military first no
he was born here in Hawaii yeah so you
went straight to the U.S army because he
didn't know what the [__] to do with his
life your younger brother younger
brother um
okay yeah
he had to climb or something one point
and he had he can't yeah obstacle course
he came down too hard
it happens yeah you jump from too high
and then you go I was recycled during
Airborne school oh you broke some [__]
too if no I sprained my [__] ankle
really bad because the the thing during
Airborne jump like you know they teach
you knees and feet together for purposes
of landing and you know absorbing but it
was a night jump so one of my feet was a
little separated from my other one and I
landed all my weight on that oh oh yeah
wow I was out for like two weeks and I
got recycled to the next class and I
just finished it yeah oh so you know why
you you probably haven't heard of most
of these because
um if you get any of those other types
of discharge you can uh go to a review
board and get it changed oh it's like a
d when you're in Community College you
just take the class again and then
they're like you gotta be can I do it
let's see can I do an extra credit
project yeah it is so most of the time
it says that people will go in and get
it reviewed and try to like upgrade the
charge or the discharge upgrade the
discharge yes that makes sense you know
what Black Hawk Down When the dude uh
was like about to repel down and they
fell down is that common
man training uh accidents like
fatalities happen
more often than you think it's it's a
dangerous game man I mean if you say
training was harder for you than the
real life then that makes sense yeah a
lot of guys especially Special
Operations die in training too damn that
shit's crazy what's the protocol or like
what's the process for if that happens
right is there any like compensatory
things for the family or is it just hey
he died no you get that 250k I don't
know how much is it now but you know you
get that
but still 250k [__] you know you're yeah
compared to life if you're ahead of the
family and like let's say your kids are
like old too like 250 is not much but
that's that's when you when you first
sign up it's like quarter mil life
insurance that goes to your family wow
I sometimes forget about death
[Music]